يعلم الجميع أن الثور يمكنه التغلب عليك
تأخذ الحياة ولكن لا أعتقد أنني إذا
أعتقد أن العكس هو ثور
يعطيها
[موسيقى]
اسمي خوسيه مانويل ميدينا وأنا
مخرطة مقلمة
التشذيب هو محظوظ لوضعه عليك
أمام وجه الثور تخلص منه
دون أن يمسك بك
الاختلافات بين العالم
من الجرح ومصارعة الثيران بشكل جيد
في الأفق لا نذهب إليه
مواجهة الثيران بدون أي
مساعدة أو عكاز أو سيف أو أي شيء
لم يلحق أي ضرر بالثور أيضًا
إنها معركة معك في عالم
قطع هناك ثلاثة أنواع من الحظ
تم تسجيل الحظ من 0 إلى 10 وجيد
يقرر القضاة أن النتيجة إذا كان
القص أو القفز أو الركض أمر جيد
لذلك ستكون النتيجة أعلى
بالنسبة لي وأنا أراه كعدو وأكثر
أرى كصديق
[موسيقى]
أنا منذ الطفولة دائمًا منذ ذلك الحين
صغير جدا اعجبني كثيرا
الثيران
وبدأت مع 89 10 سنوات في
كنائس صغيرة من هناك في بلدتي أريفالو
مع العجول الصغيرة وما إلى ذلك
[موسيقى]
قلت ذلك عندما بدأت في هذا العالم
عندما كنت أبًا ، كنت أتوقف عن ذلك
قطع ولكن في النهاية لقد كنت أبا و
أنا غير قادر على تركها
أنا الحقيقة عندما أكون أمام
وجه الثيران هو الشيء الوحيد الذي أشعر به
إنها فرحة هائلة ، السعادة التي
يجعلني أكون أمام وجه
هذا الحيوان الجميل
عندما يحين وقت التقاعد
لترك هذا لأنني أعتقد أنه لم يحدث أبدًا
التي ولد المتقلب يموت منها
قواطع
كذلك
[موسيقى]